-Every time you come on,
you always do something
above and beyond.
Thank you for playing
that game with us.
And I always kind of
put you to the test
and make you do impressions
or something.
I know -- You're like,
"I know, Jimmy.
I have a job
on 'Saturday Night Live.'
"I don't need to audition."
-They're just impressions.
-But I do love your impressions.
-Okay.
-And I was wondering
if you could do a bunch of them
and how many
you could do in 60 seconds.
If I just name the names,
could you just do a little --
Even if it's a snippet.
-A snippet?
-Just a little sound effect,
something of the names of
people that you do.
Is that possible?
-Yeah.
I want to get as many
as humanly possible.
I'm a competitor.
-Alright.
Alright, let's --
Let's go. Alright, ready?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright.
-Okay.
-60 seconds on the clock.
Ready?
Go! Meryl Streep.
-Oh, well, I have 600 Oscars.
Jimmy, you and I
are kindred spirits.
You know, you asked me on a date
once, and you said "norr."
Y'all, I just freakin'
love Oprah.
[ Laughs ]
Na, na, na, na.
Oh.
[ Laughs ]
Yaaaas!
Oh. Okay, pretend I have knives.
Whoa! Jimmy Fallon!
It is crazy that I'm here!
Oh, and I have a bow!
Shia LaBeouf?!
-Yeah.
-Yo, what's up?
What's good, Jimmy Fallon?
It's penis o'clock.
Oh, God, I-I can't see.
I got my contacts on.
-Oh, my God!
-No!
-That is unbelievable.
That is how you do it!
Chloe Fineman, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Catch the season premiere
of "Saturday Night Live"
this weekend.
We'll be right back
with a performance from Raye!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!